[Musique]
laurent cesari bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin dans la matinale de rtl
france alors pour commencer peut-être un
mot sur l'atmosphère qui règne en ce
moment l'atmosphère de tension qui règne
en ce moment aux états unis mobilisation
des pros trump lé déploiement de la
garde nationale et démission du ministre
de la sécurité intérieure destitution
contre donald trump tous ces événements
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent de cette
séquence politique que les états unis
est en train de vivre nous disent que
les états unis sont extrêmement divisée
je crois qu'ils sont en fait entrer dans
un cadre y participent
de fait le la fracture très nette
elle se trouve au sein du parti
républicain
vous avez assez que c'est à peu près à
moitié-moitié d'à peu près la moitié des
des électeurs républicains qui pense en
fait que les élections étaient truquées
jusqu'à la mise au sec est aussi un gros
tiers des démocrates qu'ils pensent
également qui continue à le penser
comme vous avez vu il ya un bon nombre
de représentants et environ huit
sénateurs qui ont voté contre la
certification des résultats
donc il ya effectivement un très fort
comment dire à une minorité trump heist
importante qui existent encore
alors parmi ces gens ceux qui le bus et
trams piste de choc des tests à peu près
tout le monde y compris y compris au
john roberts à la cour suprême et mike
pence vice-président qui pourtant a
beaucoup je suis tenu trump donc on voit
la manoeuvre ce que craignent les
démocrates c'est d'une part c'est y va
d'une part empêcher trom de ce rang plat
de de se représenter
ils veulent créer un précédent pour
montrer qu'on ne peut pas inciter à
l'insurrection et comment dire ils
veulent également les éviter comme vous
l'avez dit qu'ils prennent des grâces
préventive peut-être pas contre lui même
et commentaires pour son avocat rudy
julia ni par exemple et puis aussi qui
prennent trop d'initiatives de politique
extérieure comme
vous l'avez quand vous avez signalé les
outils classe est classée terroriste ou
plus bas classé e étage et dans le
terrorisme qui gérait tout excuser oui
laurent cesari injustement donc vous le
rappeliez les démocrates ont déposé cet
acte d'accusation contre donald trump
pourvu d'une des d'une deuxième
procédure de destitution
en parallèle le président le rappelle le
vice président mike pence à à démettre
le président de ses fonctions voilà on
le sait donald trump ne sera plus aux
affaires dans huit jours
pourquoi enclencher un tel processus
finalement aujourd'hui moi je crois les
scouts s est bien évident cc pour
embêter les républicains la sec c'est
clair du c'est le non dit elle peines ne
pourra pas aller jusqu'à jusqu'avant
flancher le 25e amendement comme nous
demander losique s'est jouée d'avancé
de ce fait il va se compromettre avec
une partie du parti républicain ensuite
on va passer donc à l'aja la mise en
accusation à la chambre où là ça va
passer sans problème puisque les
démocrates ont une majorité
ensuite pour que ça aille au sénat et ça
peut aller
ou plutôt le 19 décembre de 7 janvier
excusez moi là ça sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour la condamnation puisqu'il
faudra qu environ 18 sénateurs
républicains vote la condamnation
et ça c'est beaucoup moins garanti
puisque vous savez que la cause de la
majorité démocrate au congrès au sénat
elle est très faible donc manifestement
il ya eu bien parti républicain qui est
extrêmement divisé en ce moment que les
démocrates cherchent à fragmenter et
d'ailleurs on le voit bien puisque la
droite a déjà lancé le contre argument
qui part sur fox news qui est celui de
ne pas diviser le pays sous-entendu pas
diviser le parti en fait avec avec
l'argument quelque 74 millions de
personnes qui sont enragés
il faut les calmer sinon ça sinon sinon
tout va exploser skip pas totalement
faux non plus je les jetais vous avez
montré alors dans le corps républicain
aussi incertain demande à donald trump
de partir de lui-même
voyez d'ailleurs ce qu'a dit
pas tous mais les sénateurs républicains
c'est le 10 janvier sur nbc news la
protestation pacifique est le droit de
tout américain mais cette attaque contre
notre capital ne sera pas toléré et les
personnes impliquées seront poursuivis
dans toute la mesure de la loi
le président est tombé dans une espèce
de folie le mieux pour les états unis et
qu'il démissionne et s'en aille le plus
vite possible
alors viens de voir mike pence un qui
dénonçait d'abord les émeutes au
capitole et puis donc ce sénateur
républicain qui qui parle de folie c'est
un mot un folie pour désigner donald
trump qu'on entend également chez les
républicains est ce qu'on est plus dans
une guerre des mots où finalement il
faudrait une instance puisse acter sur
sur une folie présumé de donald trump
là je ne vois pas trop où je ne vois pas
comment j'ai la possibilité s'ils 25e
amendement ce serait que ps déclare
effectivement que le président et dont
une comme post mantis afin dé plus en
état d'assurer ses fonctions mais il
pourra pas aller jusque là
s'il fait ça il se grille complètement
pour ses chances pour la présidentielle
de 2000 24 d'autant que mon pays est sur
la même ligne extrêmement à droite et le
concurrence tout à fait donc fausse que
prête à faire le gros dos et c'est pour
ça qu'il va y avoir la procédure d
impeachment qui qui va être votée à la
chambre à cesser garantie qu de façon
jeudi à fracturer ce parti autant que le
qui a fait ce qui fera oublier pour un
temps les fractures qui sont est moins
fort et effectivement quand même ou
parti démocrate
entre une aile gauche et une majorité
centriste sans plus très court pour en
quelques mots pour conclure est-ce que
donald trump lee pourrait annoncer dans
les prochaines heures les prochaines
jours les prochains jours son départ
en tout cas ce qui pourrait en tirer un
intérêt je vois pas trop le cas que
l'intérêt lauréat à partir puisque
contraire il a intérêt à rester le plus
longtemps possible aux affaires pour
continuer à faire des mesures en sa
faveur
et puis vous connaissez son caractère il
n'aime pas dire qu'il a perdu
merci beaucoup laurence hézard et
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur d'histoire
contemporaine à l'université d'arras